we grow up in cultures with narratives
that tell us who we are by ways of
simplification and this is happening
everywhere so I am being told that if
you are coming from a Muslim geography
you are a Muslim and you can be nothing
else or this has to be your primary
identity if you if you if you go
elsewhere you know you will you will
come across the same narrative across
Europe from the far right you if you are
a Christian or if you are a Dutch just
be that you know and nothing else all
the extremist ideologies what they have
in common is they simplify complexity
yeah and they're based on identity
politics and all identity politics is
based on exclusion that's why I have a
huge problem with all kinds of organized
religions because they are based on a
distinction between us versus them and
this then the presumption that US is
better than them you know sometimes
expressed sometimes not expressed so I
do agree that we intellectuals or all
the left the Liberals have not done a
very good job in terms of connecting
with people's anxieties and we must be
critical of that but at the same time we
have to see we have to resist this
tendency to simplify things because as
human beings we are so complex we are
composed of multiple selves you know
we're made of water our main element is
water yeah it's based on flow what do I
mean is I yes I'm an Istanbul I'd i'm at
the same time a Londoner I have
connections to the Balkans I have
connections to the Middle East there is
in me so many elements from the Middle
East you know at the same time I'm a
European by choice at the same time on a
world citizen at the same time I'm a
global soul so if I can have multiple
multiple belongings there's a bigger
chance that my multiple belongings will
converge with yours but if I am based
defined on the basis of a single
exclusivist identity politics there is
no way we can find common ground we need
to abolish that narrative that tells us
you can only be one thing you can only
you know simplify the the narrative and
for that we need intellectuals we need
public interview people like you we need
people like you
we need people like you to make it
inspiring who give us new positive
visions of what it is to live the way
that you are living if people have
nowhere to jump to they will stay with
their old identifications of nationalism
and sexism if we don't give them a new
inspiring vision visions of justice
visions of human unity visions of human
meaning they'll stay where there are and
that's what we're failing to do our ass
intellectual unlike before that one of
the few who actually wanted you to go
back to humanism we need to go back to
the basics but revolutionize it
radicalize it we can't have a more
radical humanism and I know I spoke you
know I'm taking your time but if I may
add this we need to also talk about
certain subjects that we have abundant
for too long and faith is one of them I
think faith is a subject that's too
important to abandon to the religious
you know and faith is not necessarily a
religious concept when you start writing
a book it's an act of faith when you
fall in love it's an act of faith when
you move to a new city it's an act of
faith there are so many moments in our
lives that are acts of faith that have
nothing to do with religion and we also
need duct because faith without doubt
will turn into dogma so we need the
vaults we need to dance the dialectics
of faith and up these are also issues
that we don't talk about and if we don't
talk about these things people go to the
far right people go to the religious
because the reason need to talk about
these issues well I I do think that that
that there is a common thread that needs
to be emphasized between general faith
which takes courage to live more
generally and religious traditions that
emphasize a emphasized faith it to my
mind it's very important to think not a
thing simply of religions as
repositories of exclusivism I'm very
much with with Agnes we're varieties of
perspectives breed their own types of
includes exclusive isms we cannot get
over exclusive we have we can practice
boundary maintenance in a creative
and mutually enriching ways which I is
what I apparently heard you you say but
I also think that we shouldn't think of
religions great world religion simply as
associated in fanaticism I think great
word religions are repositories of our
most enduring in those potent accounts
of what makes life worth living some of
them have endured for formula for for
4,000 years some of them less than that
I think I would be weary of simply
dismissing religious traditions rather
involving them in the mutually fruitful
debate opening them up to rational
discourse in learning what might be
wisdom that might be learned from the
great great religious traditions in
particular about the meaning of life we
are bereft of meaning in our life we
will live in the culture that is so
incredibly flat in terms of experiences
that we have we have made it our
business as I said too cruel to turn
stones into bread but we have not
nurtured cultivated souls that know how
to enjoy the varieties of bread that we
are producing no wonder we are
dissatisfied give us will go back to
discard well I just want to meet two
points one but both speak you one you're
absolutely right about religion but I
think you're optimistic right now about
managing boundaries of religious
cohabitation fanatical minorities have
now the means to kill people they don't
represent Islam being the case in point
but it might easily be true of crazed
Christian evangelicals in America like
you know Boykin who thought the Iraq war
was wanted to rerun it as a crusade so
that there's a problem actually again of
the core of religions being able it's
tougher than you think in our age of
social media you know sort of homegrown
bombers and young recruits volunteers
for Isis represent a tiny minority grand
exercise a disproportionate amount of
havoc and that have a
then be no that is the kind of dynamite
of vulgar but effective campaigns I
don't make my point I think yeah right
now that the second point is also I'm
just again endorsing it really but I
think you when heroic social democracy
nevermind Marxist socialism collapsed
what the West replaced it with
essentially was shopping you know and
that it turns and that as you I think I
think it was you who said engenders new
form of perceived inequalities why can't
i have that bigger car that bigger house
and so on and so that the whole promise
of America which is a fantastic and
bizarre mysterious promise the pursuit
of happiness then commensurately becomes
the fury of unhappiness because of
radically unequal shopping opportunities
you know so you are absolutely right
about we need to do something about that
you actually we're all witnesses over
time in history where everything is
happening too fast and I think this is
quite dangerous I mean we've seen this
in Turkey every day something new
happens every week something new happens
and there's barely any time to stop and
think and analyze and digest you're
being catapulted into the next event and
the next event that's why we need these
intellectual exchanges this maybe I'm
simplifying but broadly speaking we are
being pulled into very opposite
directions and the second trend is
gaining speed right now yes on the one
hand we had high hopes you know about
world citizens global souls
internationalism multiculturalism which
is not a favorable word anymore and then
the other one the tribalism isolationism
the illusion that sameness will bring
safety this is what we are being
spoon-fed right now they're telling us
if you are being surrounded by people
who are exactly like you who dress up
like you speak like you who come from
the same background you'll be safe it's
an illusion we are far too globalized to
have this weather we have walls actually
physical walls or not sameness will not
bring our safety how do we break this
vicious circle so I want to focus on the
on the similar patterns also with
regards to religion and and I hear what
you're saying of course it's wrong to
say that religion is completely negative
but religions exclude a lot in organized
religions exclude a lot and you're right
we need meaning but perhaps there's
another way of doing that maybe it says
it needs on a different name a third
approach which has not been named yet
which understands spirituality which
understands faith and at the same time
resists being organized resist being
part of any trial and for me approaches
that cultivate individualism because I
come from a very collectivistic society
where you belong two tribes political
tribes so anything that cultivates
individualism is very precious because
fascism and neo-fascism these are
collectivistic diseases you need masses
multiplicities and as human beings we
are affected by the energy of other
people so if your best friend is biased
against Armenians that energy affects
you when you're alone it's a different
story so in that lonely space I think
there's room for spirituality for faith
when it's an organized religion in the
public space it's a completely different
time I generally
[Applause]
you